ils ne sont que très rarement ouvert à
la presse par crainte d'espionnage
industriel la visite des ateliers loir
et chérien de la célèbre marque de sacs
à main vuitton était donc très attendu
parmi les 18 sites français deux sont à
vendôme inauguration en grande pompe
aujourd'hui avec les grands patrons du
groupe lvmh et bruno le maire -ministre
de l'économie et de la relance reportage
sur place d'hélène chapelet
à droite l'homme le plus riche de france
à gauche le ministre de l'économie
pourtant pas question de parler de gros
sous à l'inauguration des deux ateliers
vuitton implanté en loir et cher ici
c'est l'excellence française que l'on
souhaite mettre en valeur et l'ancrage
local au coeur des territoires dans le
vendômois le maroquinier de luxe a déjà
recruté 200 personnes il souhaite à
terme créer 500 emplois
auparavant christ elle était assistante
maternelle elle est en formation depuis
novembre dernier pour intégrer de
manière définitive
l'effectif vuitton c'est toujours d'un
attrait pour les activités manuelles
avec mes enfants dans mon ancien métier
quand j'étais assistant pat hamel donc
mon agenda ne prévoyait pas que je
termine maroquinière celle du thon mais
j'ai cette chance et
c'est incroyable en fait de pouvoir
apprendre si rapidement des gestes qui
sont ancestraux comme ça c'est très
intense mais c'est ce que du bonheur la
majorité de ses salariés n'avaient
jamais touché une aiguille avant
d'entrer chez vuitton tous ont été
formés en interne à l'école des
savoir-faire 12 mois minimum pour
apprendre à travailler les cuirs
exotiques comme le piton le lézard ou
l'alligator on va apprendre déjà
l'utilisation de nos machines à coudre
ou tout simplement toutes les
spécificités qui vont aller qui vont
aller de pair avec notre matière
exotiques si donc c'est donc un
savoir-faire très particulier toutes les
matières différentes vont s'approcher de
façon différente on apprendra donc à les
manipuler avec le temps en fonction de
leur réaction
après et direction vendôme et le
quartier rochambeau c'est là que le
deuxième atelier vuitton s'est installée
l'ancien bâtiment classé a été
totalement
et pour accueillir un atelier de
fabrication de sacs à main si tous les
postes ne sont pas encore pourvus le
patron a des arguments convaincants pour
trouver de la main d'oeuvre
au delà du salaire vous avez un
intéressement résultat qui peut aller
michael jusqu'à 10 mois 18 mois de
salaire
par an mais donc chez vuitton quand on
entre chez vuitton on a envie de rester
en 2021 le numéro un mondial du luxe
lvmh a réalisé un bénéfice record de 12
milliards d'euros un résultat supérieur
à ceux réalisés avant la pandémie 30
milliards d'euros de ventes ont été
réalisées grâce à la mode et à la
maroquinerie